could china help end russia's invasion
of ukraine
beijing appears split between supporting
its close ally moscow and condemning the
war so what are the options for chinese
leaders this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum china is one of russia's
closest allies and trading partners
tense relations with the u.s and europe
have pushed the neighbors even closer in
recent years but beijing has come under
international pressure to condemn the
invasion of ukraine which goes against
its own stated principle of protecting
sovereignty and non-interference
while russia's finance minister has
suggested china could help lessen the
impact of western economic sanctions
a third of moscow's 640 billion dollars
in foreign reserves is held in the
chinese currency yuan the u.s national
security advisor made this warning just
before meeting china's top foreign
policy advisor in italy
we have made it clear to not just
beijing but every country in the world
that if
they think that they can basically bail
russia out they can give russia a
workaround to the sanctions that we've
imposed
they should have another thing coming
because we will ensure that neither
china nor anyone else can compensate
russia for these losses u.s media say
moscow has asked beijing for military
help in ukraine china's foreign ministry
denied this calling the accusation
disinformation
recently the us has been spreading
disinformation against china in regards
to ukraine time after time with sinister
intentions
china's position on ukraine is
consistent and clear and we have always
played a constructive role in persuading
peace and promoting talks
we'll bring in our guests in a moment
first let's take a closer look at the
ties between china and russia
the two neighbors share a border that's
more than 4 000 kilometers long
their economies complement one another
with energy and raw materials going to
china and industrial products heading to
russia
both are united in their rivalry with
the u.s and their leaders often speak of
their country's historical greatness
president xi jinping and vladimir putin
declared a strategic partnership last
month they signed a so-called no limits
agreement where they pledged to support
each other no matter what
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in beijing andy monk senior
research fellow at the center for china
and globalization in brussels theresa
fallon director of the center for russia
europe asia studies and in alexandria
virginia heino klink a former u.s deputy
assistant secretary of defense for east
asia a warm welcome to you all and
thanks for joining us today on inside
story teresa let me start with you today
could china actually help end russia's
invasion of ukraine is this something
that's within the realm of possibility
well after all today is day 19 we
haven't seen china actually
condemn russia's invasion of ukraine at
all so i think that there
as high representative joseph burl of
the european union had reached out and
said said that china was the only
country that could possibly do some
mediation but i haven't seen too many
moves on china's part
but of course everyone wants a
diplomatic
end to this disaster but i think that
what's more telling is what happened on
february 4th with the joint agreement
that was signed by putin and she just in
the run-up to the olympics which
declared the relationship as you know
beyond limits so some analysts have seen
this as a molotov rib and drop
non-aggression pact shortly after that
putin was able to move his troops from
russia's far east to ukraine so he
couldn't have done that without the
taste support of china so china is
walking a tightrope in all of this it
has economic interest with the west big
markets in europe and the us but at the
same time it has this arrangement with
russia so they are trying to speak out
of both sides out of their mouth you
could say andy you heard teresa there
talk about this tightrope that china is
having to walk right now it does appear
that beijing is split between supporting
moscow and condemning the war
what are the options right now for
chinese leaders
well i think china's been very clear on
this and i think teresa is engaging in a
little bit of fallacious uh thinking or
at least fallacious argumentation here
in that i think china absolutely uh has
called for a peaceful resolution uh to
the situation in ukraine
condemning russia would be choosing a
side and i think what the situation
really needs uh as wang yi i believe has
said uh multiple times
is really
cool restraint not to exacerbate the
situation and we need to recognize too
that certainly uh china like russia like
many other countries around the world
face a very challenging situation in
dealing with a violent and really
schizophrenic sociopathic uh country if
we were to just describe the us
as a person
why schizophrenic is that because it's
fundamentally unreliable we don't know
every four years uh there could be a 180
degree policy shift which makes it very
very difficult uh
the violent part of it of course we've
seen from uh iraq to
afghanistan in recent years
really uh causing incalculable damage
and human casualties around the world so
it's really a difficult situation i
think china is playing a uh a positive
role as our uh president uh while huayal
wrote in the new york times today
that really there can be a diplomatic
off-ramp and i think china can play a
positive role here andy just to follow
up with you very quickly because i was
going to ask you about that op-ed in the
new york times that's from your
colleague at the center for china and
globalization
when it comes to this idea of
an off-ramp with china's help is this
feasible and is this a role that chinese
leadership really wants to play right
now
well i think that's a very very good
question in that
um this is a very very delicate
difficult situation i think for uh all
countries involved i think the big
challenge here
is uh the quote-unquote west but
certainly uh the u.s has
uh repeatedly i think uh
not recognized the legitimacy
of uh russia's security concerns and
that this really has exacerbated
uh the situation and you know it seems
that the us certainly is willing to
fight russia down to the last ukrainian
and in this very volatile situation
i think every country can play a role in
china as a major power certainly has
called for a peaceful solution teresa i
can see that you want to respond and i'm
going to give you that chance let me
just go to hino and ask him as well
haina what does the u.s expect from
china right now
the united states as well as the rest of
the world and certainly the members of
the united nations expect china to play
a productive role
and
and when i say that
you know it reflects um very clearly on
china its leadership
uh and the regime led by the ccp and how
it voted in the u.n it abstained
if the chinese want to actually be a
major power on the world stage and want
to be what we used to refer to the bush
administration a responsible stakeholder
china certainly needs to step up to the
plate
and
remember russia invaded another united
nations member a sovereign country a
country by the way that
china had very good relationship with a
country that joined the bri back in 2017
if i'm not mistaken
and we see the brutality of the russian
invasion that in my opinion the chinese
are complicit in because at a minimum
they knew that the russians were going
to do that
based on their own intelligence
capabilities and their own uh very
special relationship with russia
theresa i'm going to go ahead and give
you a chance to respond i also saw that
you were nodding along to some of what
hino said as well so please go ahead and
jump in
i mean i think beijing is trying to do a
very carefully cultivated ambiguous pose
and this one of their number one foreign
policy issues is
not to use force to change borders so
russia did that yet they chose to ignore
that that's one of their key
uh pillars of their foreign policy so
they are really willing to take a lot
from the russians in addition to that a
chinese ambassador has announced that
this is a great opportunity for china to
buy a lot of things
in russia because there's all these
sanctions in russia companies are
leaving russia we see a long list of all
the different organizations willing to
leave russia so the chinese are looking
at it as a fire sale is a great
opportunity for them so i think that uh
they have seen a very diminished russia
on their doorstep so if you look at the
matryoshkido we're the smallest little
piece right now and this is much to
china's benefit also we saw after 2014
after russia's annexation of crimea
russia turned more towards china created
some energy deals and you know knocked
down prices and in the february fourth
agreement we saw in that agreement you
know it's in black and white it's
available to everyone free it's not
salacious or fallacious i don't know
which adjective you were using but i
think this is you know black and white
we see where russia and china stood they
said they were creating the new contours
of the international order so we saw
this kind of relationship
they've met with each other 38 times and
they've described the relationship
between she and putin as the best in 300
years and let's remember xi jinping
spoke to putin after the invasion he
didn't speak to zielinski of the
ukrainian leader so i think that we have
to keep this in in mind and i think
china would love to rebrand themselves
as a peacemaker but we are on day 19 and
i think the big ask now will be that
russia uh assets which are in some
chinese banks should also be sanctioned
will china this will be the real
bellwether of china's role on the
international stage will they allow
their banks to be chinese russian assets
to be sanctioned in chinese banks i know
it looked like you wanted to jump in i
also want to follow up with you about
something you mentioned a moment ago um
that abstention in the unsc uh by china
when it comes to that resolution that
would have deplored russia's russia's
invasion of ukraine the reason i want to
ask about that is because that was taken
to mean different things by different
players uh some interpreted it as a
diplomatic win by russia some said it
was a diplomatic win by the west do you
believe it was a diplomatic win for
either the west or for russia and why
well i think it's indicative of china
walking that tightrope quite frankly but
at a certain point in the nation's
history
countries and their uh leaders need to
make choices
does the prc want to be on the side of
putin who has launched uh invasions
against a number of its neighbors
georgia ukraine in europe as well as
participate in the brutal suppression of
people in syria and other places in the
world or
does china want to be
on the side of
the vast majority of the countries that
voted for that resolution i think it is
a win
in that at least the chinese did not
align themselves
uh with north korea belarus and eritrea
that is a win i guess you could say for
us but again how reflective is that
of
the
uh strategic calculus that's going on in
zhong nang hai
andy is there any concern among
yeah andy i'll let you jump in actually
go ahead and then i'll ask my question
well i want to make a couple of points
here
first i think teresa talks about this
very important
notion of sovereignty which china makes
a cornerstone of its foreign policy but
i think some people perhaps being
mischievous or some people perhaps
not fully recognizing the complexities
of the situation in ukraine is that
china can respect sovereignty while also
acknowledging that sovereignty can be
forfeited when a country acts in a way
as to be so threatening to a neighboring
country that some action has to be taken
and i think that we can accept this
more nuanced view as
legitimate without taking a position on
whether what ukraine did rises to that
level
and i think the other thing that we risk
falling into i think a very typical
u.s uh binary manatean way of thinking
is that there's only two sides you're
either with us or against us and i think
what china has shown is that there is a
third way and china is saying uh we hope
we are on the side of development
peaceful development we hope that every
country uh that has some state whether
that's economic political
uh humanitarian
uh really should uh do what it can to
foster a peaceful solution here um and i
think this is uh really the key issue uh
that the framing is problematic and uh
you know
very typical of the way the u.s
approaches these and it's also important
to point out too there's really not the
whole world here that is on the side of
the us and western europe india also
stay in the uae as well and i believe
india is making active preparations uh
for a rupee ruble settlement system so
there really is uh a third point of view
here that perhaps uh is the most uh
effective and uh likeliest way out of
this
terrible situation andy let me ask you
this as a follow-up um if this continues
to drag on
is there a growing concern among
officials in china
that if china continues to stand by
russia at some point the costs are going
to outweigh the benefits
well again i would question that premise
muhammad that is china standing by
russia now certainly uh theresa is
correct uh
in early february uh presidency and
putin
did sign and announce a
a relationship
that often is described in the media as
quote unquote no limits a new kind of
relationship and that is not i think
mutually exclusive with wanting to see a
peaceful solution being
an honest broker uh perhaps in this and
that this is a complex situation
everyone from george cannon to henry
kissinger to john niersheimer uh has
said including i think some u.s
ambassadors
previous ambassadors and said that what
the us is doing in the ukraine
clearly is a provocation and is going to
cause this kind of
reaction from russia sooner or later and
as the chinese like to say perhaps some
self-reflection uh is in order here
teresa from your vantage point what is
china going to be expecting from russia
and you know you mentioned earlier that
so far
chinese banks financial entities have
not cut ties with russia is there a
scenario that exists where you think
that that could happen at some point
that remains to be seen how china
responds to the international
communities
china china's not helping whatsoever on
sanctions we know that so when the
international community asks them to
support these sanctions uh i think that
will be about whether whether they're
really an international player and if
they have good intentions i think that
the fact that this agreement was inked
february 4th and the invasion took place
on 23rd speaks volumes we also know that
china started to fill their strategic
petroleum reserve spr
after meeting with putin uh and also
buying more grain and wheat
understanding most likely you can draw
your own conclusions that a war was on
its way so i think that uh as heinous
pointed out
ukraine had great relations with with
china so they're not really much of a
friend are they in fact china got their
first aircraft carrier from from the
ukrainians and they said it was going to
be a casino so we've seen a lot of
deception in this relationship and let's
not forget
the way this is being framed by andy is
pretty much what the russians are saying
so it's almost a magnification of the
disinformation most analysts see the
invasion of ukraine as unprovoked and i
think that to say that ukraine has no
sovereignty it's not a country that is
definitely right out of russia's
narrative and lastly the final point i'd
like to make in regard to disinformation
we've seen chinese officials it was
printed in xinhua they wrote a quote uh
from the high representative joseph
perel of the eu saying china was a peace
loving superpower but he never said that
so this disinformation machine is just
rolling on
i know um
if china
as well andy i'll let you make your
point just a minute let me just ask hino
a question here um
how do the us and western allies feel
about having china potentially play a
role in de-escalating this conflict
well if china were to play a positive
role it would be welcomed i just think
that many of us who have spent their
professional lives working with the
chinese and the chinese government and
the chinese communist party are not
particularly optimistic
the chinese
will view this uh as an opportunistic
chance to better their position both
bilaterally with russia take advantage
of the economic straits that the russian
regime finds itself in as well as
to play a spoiler role vis-a-vis the
united states uh and europe and not just
europe but
the west meaning other countries such as
japan and australia i think
fundamentally we cannot lose sight of
the fact
that what we see today
is
a blatant violation of national
sovereignty
uh of the intel the territorial
integrity of of ukraine and the russians
launching a brutal onslaught against the
civilian population of ukraine the fact
that ukraine as a sovereign country uh
with a president that was elected by the
people
wanted to have closer relationships with
the european union and nato should not
have been a causes belly to necessitate
or warrant russians putting in almost
200 000 troops and killing thousands of
ukrainian civilians andy i do want to
ask this russia's finance minister had
suggested that china could help lessen
the impact of western economic sanctions
how much
will china be able to help russia
economically
well i want to respond to teresa's point
about
russian disinformation i mean would she
or would theresa would you then consider
again george cannon henry kissinger john
mearsheimer uh several former us
ambassadors who've said exactly the same
thing also purveyors of russian
disinformation
and kino i would say that uh certainly
the loss of life uh in ukraine is tragic
but is it any more brutal than the u.s
uh attacks against iraq and afghanistan
where countless civilians women and
children were killed and maimed and made
homeless is it any less brutal
teresa let me ask you
do you think that there is a scenario
that exists whereby china
would cut ties with russia not just
economic ties diplomatic ties condemn
the invasion of ukraine the conflicts
going on and if so
what would china stand to lose or gain
as a result
i think the international community
would love to see china support
international norms u.n conventions and
all of these important issues but their
actions so far on day 19 have proven
that they aren't doing that and that
they are trying to actually it would be
welcomed as hyena said but i think what
they haven't um
it's been a stress test and they've
actually did a lot of
learning because russia uh
what they've done in ukraine china can
watch how the international community
has responded and i think they were not
expecting to see such a united west they
expected to see a divided at europe
maybe a week in nato but in and we've
even seen um
neutral countries like switzerland
traditionally neutral actually uh join
in on the sanctions on the banks and
also we've seen neutral countries like
sweden send uh lethal aid to ukraine so
the world is changing and i think china
better you know wake up to what is
happening and that's this idea of a
third way there is you know law and
there is against law so either they
support uh
the international community and the
united nations and what they've signed
up to in addition to that uh beijing
also signed an agreement to uh guarantee
ukraine's sovereignty uh
it was a side agreement along with the
budapest memorandum in 1994 so
the prc is not honoring their agreement
there either so i think that it's all
nice to say these things diplomatically
but what are they really doing i think
now is the time and i think the meeting
that will take place in rome will really
show
whether china is actually going to do
something or if they're just going to
talk a lot i know is there a lot of
concern among american officials right
now that china would be able to
lessen the impact of economic sanctions
on russia that they would be able to
help blunt the impact on on russia
through through workarounds or through
economic support
that is certainly a concern and uh the
unfortunate history
of chinese enforcement of sanctions
united nations imposed sanctions for
instance against other countries such as
north korea
has not been particularly stellar so
there's certainly a precedent
for the chinese not enforcing sanctions
i think what we see today in europe
what russia's actions have done in terms
of pushing more and more countries
towards and wanting to integrate with
the european union wanting to integrate
with nato and diplomatically for
instance uh doing unprecedented things
such again as is the case of switzerland
that teresa mentioned
should also serve as a parallel example
to china because in the asia pacific we
have seen over the last several years
chinese actions pushing more and more
countries
to start to form a more against chinese
aggression chinese assertiveness and
chinese economic coercion
and i think what we will find is that
those trends which are not favorable to
china will continue and what will be
necessary to stop those types of trends
will be for china to start becoming more
productive and in
in
opposing malign activities all right
well we have run out of time so we're
going to have to leave the conversation
there thanks so much to all of our
guests andy mock teresa fallon and heino
clink
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website alzheimer.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jim the whole team here bye
for now
[Music]